I understand this afternoon that a
business lender founded by a prominent
former conservative party donor is in
detailed talks to buy the British
operations of Silicon Valley Bank which
of course collapsed last week in the U.S
I've learned that Oak North Bank which
was set up by Rishi kosler in 2015 and
counts the former Tory Chancellor Lord
Hammond as an advisor is in talks with
banking regulators and the government
about an offer to buy a Silicon Valley
Bank UK now my sources tell me that a
formal offer would still be subject to
due diligence potentially lasting for
several days but that Oak North is
hoping to secure regulatory approval for
its offer as early as this evening now
this has all of course been triggered by
the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank in
the U.S which is seeing it taken under
government control there in the UK the
bank of England has said that it plans
to place the lender into insolvency
proceedings although efforts to find a
buyer will continue overnight amid
warnings from technology entrepreneurs
but the demise of the company in the UK
will cause huge numbers of casualties
among startup companies now Oak North
isn't the only company trying to buy
Silicon Valley Bank UK we reported
yesterday on Sky News about interest
from a much younger company called the
bank of London and there is also
interest from an Abu Dhabi state-backed
investment vehicle called adq so there
is some hope that Silicon Valley Bank
UK's operations can still be salvaged
despite the frenetic nature of the talks
over its future